hello everyone let's talk about kinetic
energy now kinetic might be an
unfamiliar word but it just comes from a
greek word that means of motion so
kinetic energy is energy from motion
any massive object that is in motion
then has kinetic energy but how much
first let's consider some comparisons
this nice rat family papa mama brother
and sister are sitting down to dinner at
a long table passing blocks of cheese
back and forth paparat asks for the
cheddar cheese and there are two
identical blocks brother rat pushes one
and sister wrap pushes the other so that
the second cheese is traveling twice as
fast as the first cheese which piece of
cheddar cheese do you think has more
kinetic energy
yes it's the one going faster
now paparat doesn't need both pieces of
cheddar so he eats one and sends one
back along with a small piece of swiss
that weighs half as much as the piece of
cheddar papa rat has better manners than
his children so he sends them both back
at the same speed
which piece of cheese would you think
has more kinetic energy now
yes the heavier or more massive object
in this case the cheddar will have more
kinetic energy
let's make it a little more complicated
brother and sister rat are full so they
send the cheeses back for mama rat
brother rat pushes the larger piece of
cheddar and sister wrap pushes the
smaller piece of swiss so that the swiss
is going twice as fast as the cheddar
now which cheese has more kinetic energy
in fact it turns out that it's the swiss
in this scenario kinetic energy depends
on both mass and speed but the
dependence on speed is stronger
this estimation of kinetic energy can be
quantified in an equation that lets us
calculate kinetic energy exactly we said
kinetic energy depends on the mass and
the speed which we'll write as v for
velocity so we can start with ke equals
m times v
but we said that it depends more on the
speed so the velocity here is actually
squared
this means that if an object's mass
doubles its kinetic energy also doubles
but if its speed doubles the kinetic
energy actually quadruples
and there's also a constant factor of
one-half at the beginning of the
equation but we won't go into the
details of the math of deriving this
today so this is the equation for
kinetic energy one-half mv squared let's
apply this equation to our cheesy
example say the swiss has a mass of .05
kilograms which makes the cheddar's mass
0.1 kilograms
when both cheeses have the same speed
say 2 meters per second the chatter's
kinetic energy is one-half times 0.1
kilograms times 2 meters per second
squared which is 0.2 joules the swiss's
kinetic energy is one-half times .05
kilograms times two meters per second
squared which is 0.1 joules or half the
kinetic energy of the cheddar so we can
see that at the same speed the cheddar
has more kinetic energy because it has
more mass
but when the swiss has a speed of 4
meters per second and the chatter still
has a speed of two meters per second the
swiss's kinetic energy is now one half
times point zero five kilograms times
four meters per second squared which is
point four joules so now the kinetic
energy of the swiss is twice the kinetic
energy of the cheddar so we can see that
even though the cheddar has more mass
the swiss has more kinetic energy
because it's going faster
in summary kinetic energy is the motion
energy of an object the equation for
kinetic energy is one-half mv squared so
as mass increases kinetic energy
increases like the more massive cheddar
versus the swiss
and as velocity increases kinetic energy
increases even more like the speedy
swiss versus the slower cheddar
thanks for watching and i hope you
learned a little bit of something